[Music]
in life and in death
we give glory
uh hello
you shouldn't be out here it's not safe
what the hell
hey can you hear me
it's you
the child's father
child
hey wait do you mean rose is she here
rose
rose yes
she is in great danger
since mother miranda brought her to the
village we have fallen into darkness
what are you talking about the
bell monsters danger
they're coming
no
wait where's rose who's mother miranda
the bell tolls for us all
they're coming again
uh
ugh
close the door
please
hey what are you doing here
stay back please
don't hurt us whoa
it's okay
i'm not gonna hurt you
i'm just glad to see normal people at
last
have you seen any other survivors
no
they're all in louise's house
and she's not answering in the gate is
locked quiet girl
he's an outsider
oh
[__] we're setting ducks in here can
your old man walk
no
one of the monsters cut him he's lost a
lot of blood we have to get into
louise's house quiet
there must be a way inside
stay here
be quiet and don't move until i get
those gates open
[Applause]
huh
come on it's clear
hurry hurry
took your damn time
you're welcome
he's not used to relying on other people
i'm sorry
we'll be safe in here
won't we
safer here than out there that's for
sure
hey
do you know anything about what's going
on around here
it doesn't make any sense
mother miranda has always protected us
nobody's answered
father
we have to get inside
hello
anybody home
maybe a familiar voice
louisa open up it's me elena
stop
shouting you'll draw the monsters
calm down who's this my friend stay back
father
for god's sake julian let us in no
they'll smell the blood you'll endanger
us all my father will die out here
that's not my problem what's going on
these people want to let a dying man
into our home come now these people are
our friends go on go inside
come now this way
you're not from this village
ah
no
i'm ethan
eulen go make yourself useful and check
the grounds
i said go
well
if elena trusts you
then so do i
come inside ethan
wait here i'll check on the others
this way
come inside the others are waiting
what the [__] is this
outsiders you're gonna get us all killed
guys anton
he helped leonardo and elena we were
doing fine by ourselves please ethan
take a seat
is this all that's left from your entire
village all that's left
all that's left
there is no one left
a worthless
invalid
a stupid
whaling [__]
and you
you drag a bloody man and an outsider in
here like it's nothing
and expect to be all safe
there is no safe
every sorry bastard out there has been
ripped in half
but tomorrow
tomorrow we'll all be dead
just like her damn husband
the bitter soccer roxanna that's enough
this house has protected my family for
generations
and drunk or not
you are all welcome and safe in here
whatever
can someone please tell me what the hell
is going on here we don't know
one day we were a quiet devout village
and the next the monsters came and
attacked us
and they
they kept coming wait louisiana
where is your husband
did they no
no he he is out there
somewhere he
he he went to get help
yes yes that's
that's it he he went to fetch help
let us pray
for him
for all of us
good idea
come
gather
great ones
hear our voice
together as one in reverence
we call on thee
within the endless dark
as the midnight moon rises on black
wings
so we make our sacrifice
and await the light at the end
in life
the tea should be ready
come help me elena please
that prayer
i've heard it before there was an old
woman near the graveyard
give me that
some [__] as crazy as a bag of rats
there is wisdom
in her devotion though
and i hope it protected her as it shall
protect us
[Laughter]
what are you doing leonardo what's wrong
are you okay
elena don't stay back
no let me go
let it go
elena
i said no
oh my god
i'm so sorry father hey
hey that wasn't your father anymore you
did the right thing
[Applause]
elena elena no
there's nothing you can do
this entire place is collapsing
you couldn't save him
he was already gone
leave me alone no we're getting out of
here
together
i gotta get out of here
uh
damn the fire's moving fast
what are you thinking step back we can
bust out with this
are you all right i'm fine
let me back up again
the fire
there isn't any time
i don't want to go
grab on hurry
let's move
don't worry and try not to breathe in
the smoke
i know thank you ethan
you're kind
i hope your family is safe i do too
come on it'll hold
there that's our way out oh thank god
but what then
the village is still full of monsters
we can't fight them there's too many hey
hey don't talk like that
we'll find a safe house to put you in
until i can find my daughter
my hunch is she's in that old castle no
that place is full of nothing but blood
and death
and i don't want to be alone while
you're
father
elena no that's not him not anymore
he said my name
father wait it's not safe oh
stay there
come on give me your hand
ethan go
save your daughter
elena don't give up
reach for me
why is everyone dying on me
this is just too much
i just
don't get it
this place is going mad
why the [__] is this happening again
oh [__]
[Applause]
hey
[Laughter]
who was
what was that
foreign
death
yes
death has visited them all
[Laughter]
guess this leads to the
castle
nothing but blood and death huh